This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the most wonderful time of the year. It's mini story season. Gather the kids around the fire because we have a year and mix of short stories about a rogue architect, spooky kitchens, a 100 year old music streaming service, and the crazy way the French try to make telling time less crazy. Let's go.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是一年中最为美妙的时光，也就是我们的迷你故事季。大家围坐在火炉旁吧，因为我们准备了一系列短篇故事，涵盖叛逆的建筑师、诡异的厨房、一个拥有百年历史的音乐流媒体服务，以及法国人试图让看时间变得不那么疯狂的疯狂举动。我们开始吧。
So we are here with producer Chris Barouba, Hey, Chris. Hello, Roman. What do you have for us? Okay, so I've been very into the French Revolution recently. I know there's been these online trends of people reading up about the Roman Empire, but you know, I'm a little different. I'm kind of zigging where other people are sagging. I don't know if you knew this about me. I didn't know this. I mean, why exactly are you reading about the French Revolution? I don't know. I mean, I've been on a bit of a history camp.
所以我们今天请到了制作人克里斯·巴鲁巴，嘿，克里斯。你好，罗曼。你给我们带来了什么？好的，我最近对法国大革命非常着迷。我知道网上现在有一种潮流，大家都在阅读古罗马帝国的历史，但你知道的，我和他们有点不一样。我是那种喜欢剑走偏锋的人。我不知道你对我是不是了解这一点。我确实不知道。我是说，你到底为什么要读法国大革命？我不知道。我的意思是，我最近一直在恶补历史。
And the French Revolution is interesting. I mean, the French Revolutionaries, they saw themselves as the beginning of history, right? Like, this is a whole new way of doing things. They're just trying lots of new things, like new system of government, a reign of terror, just new everything. New country with new laws and new ways of working that was very rational. Roman, that is Don Norman, the author of a book called The Design of Everyday Things, and a favorite of 99% visible. Absolutely.
而且法国大革命很有趣。我的意思是，法国大革命的革命者们，他们将自己视为历史的开端，对吧？就像，这是一种全新的做事方式。他们只是在尝试很多新东西，比如新的政府体制、恐怖统治，简直是万象更新。一个拥有新法律和新工作方式的新国家，而且非常理性。罗曼，那是唐·诺曼，也就是《设计心理学》（The Design of Everyday Things）一书的作者，也是 99% Invisible 的老朋友。完全正确。
I mean, my friend in college giving me a copy of The Design of Everyday Things is probably one of the reasons why this show exists. I mean, he's that pivotal. He's like our spiritual godfather. Totally. And Don actually talks about the French Revolution in that book, because as part of this new rational society
我的意思是，大学时朋友送我的一本《设计心理学》，可能就是这个节目存在的理由之一。我的意思是，他的地位就是如此关键。他就像是我们的精神教父。完全赞同。唐在那本书里确实谈到了法国大革命，因为作为这个全新理性社会的一部分，
they were building the French introduced an idea called decimalization, which is a system of measurements that uses 10 as the base number. So they switched everything, that's where kilograms, that's where grams and kilograms comes from, and meters. So the idea behind that is when things are divisible by 10, it's just easier to do math. Guess what, I have 10 fingers. So this base system of 10 decimalizations where the metric system comes in,
他们在建设的过程中，法国人引入了一个叫做“十进位制”（decimalization）的概念，这是一种以 10 为基数的计量系统。所以他们改变了一切，这就是千克、克、千克以及米的由来。背后的理念就是，当数字可以被 10 整除时，做数学运算就会变得更容易。你猜怎么着，我有 10 根手指。所以这种以 10 为基础的十进制系统，就是公制系统的来源。
they also had this idea for something called decimal time. Huh. So Roman, in a standard day, like we have now, we have 24 hours, each hour has 60 minutes, and each minute has 60 seconds. Correct, I am familiar with that one, yes. Right, so we've had that for a really long time. However, after the French Revolution, the legislative body, the convention, they wanted to try this
他们当时还提出了一个叫做“十进制时间”（decimal time）的概念。嗯。所以罗曼，在标准的一天中，就像我们现在这样，我们有 24 小时，每小时有 60 分钟，每分钟有 60 秒。没错，我很熟悉这个，是的。对的，所以我们已经使用这种时间制度很长时间了。然而，在法国大革命之后，立法机构国民公会，他们想尝试这种
new system of time that was based on decimalization. They're like, this is a new idea. Ignoring the fact China had something similar to this up until the 17th century, but ignore that. Ignore that. This is the French, you know, they're saying this is our new idea. And this whole system, everything had a base of 10. So basically, everything could be divided by 10. They tried to say, well, let's see, there should be 10 days in the week, right? And there should be 10 hours in the day. Okay, well, there's a lot to sort of like figure out
基于十进制的新时间系统。他们觉得，这是一个新想法。尽管中国在 17 世纪之前也有类似的东西，但先不管这个。忽略不计。这是法国人嘛，你知道的，他们说这是我们的新想法。而这个整个系统，一切都以 10 为基数。基本上，所有东西都可以被 10 整除。他们试图说，好吧，让我们看看，一周应该有 10 天，对吧？一天应该有 10 小时。好吧，有很多事情需要去
all the repercussions of that. Oh, yeah. Okay, so 10 day weeks. Yeah, so 10 days a week, and actually it wasn't called a week in the system. It was called a decade just to make everything a little more confusing. Okay. And the biggest challenge is this idea of the 10 hour day. So 10 hour days each hour would have 100 minutes. Each minute would have 100 seconds. Okay. And you might have noticed, that doesn't quite add up to the same length of a day that we have right now.
理清它所带来的一切连锁反应。哦，是的。好吧，10 天为一周。是的，所以一周有 10 天，而且在这个系统中它其实不叫周（week）。它被称为“旬”（decade），只是为了让一切变得更让人困惑一点。好吧。而最大的挑战就是这个 10 小时一天的概念。所以 10 小时一天，每小时有 100 分钟。每分钟有 100 秒。好吧。你可能已经注意到了，这跟我们现在一天的实际长度并不完全对等。
10 hour days, 100 minutes. Okay, that's. I could see you doing the math. I could see you. Is that gonna be, is that close to what we have now or longer, longer? It'd be longer. Yeah, the day would be longer in that situation,
每天 10 小时，每分钟 100 秒。好吧，这个。我能看出你在做数学计算。我看得出来。这跟我们现在的时间长度差不多，还是更长，更长？会更长。是的，在这种情况下，一天的时间会变得更长，
but the way to make it work, so the length of the day doesn't change, is actually you could change the length of a second. So instead of a second being one steam boat, it could be one steam buck. So like you have a shorter second, and that would make the math work, so the day would be the same length. Wow. Okay. Okay. So the French developed this new, more rational way
但为了让它行得通，让一天的总长度保持不变，实际上你可以改变一秒的长度。所以，一秒钟不再是一次蒸汽船的呼吸，而可以是一次蒸汽微动。这样你就有了一个更短的秒，数学上就能行得通，一天的长度也就保持不变了。哇。好吧。好吧。所以法国人开发了这种更新、更理性的方式
of keeping in time, but how did they get people to accept one steam as the link that was second? Like how did you implement this? Well, the French introduced this new calendar with like 10 day weeks and this new time keeping system in 10 other days in 1793. And it didn't go great right away to be honest. I should say they kind of half introduced it, like officially
来保持时间，但是他们是如何让人们接受“一蒸汽”作为秒的长度的呢？你究竟是怎么推行这个的呢？嗯，法国人在 1793 年推出了这个包含 10 天一周以及这个全新计时系统的新日历。说实话，一开始进展得并不是很顺利。我应该说他们算是一半推行了它，因为官方层面
France switched over to this new system. But according to accounts from the time, only some people were half using it, like people were just getting adjusted to it. And to help ease the transition, they actually made up these special clocks that had both the systems of time on the clock face. So, Roman, take a look at this. Okay. So, the interface has 100 seconds to a minute, and then it also has the 60 seconds in an hour on the outside ring, so it helps you with the conversion.
法国确实切换到了这个新系统。但根据当时的记录，只有一部分人在半推半就地使用它，大家还在适应的过程中。为了帮助人们平稳过渡，他们实际上还特意制作了这种特殊的时钟，表盘上同时拥有两套时间系统。所以，罗曼，来看看这个。好的。所以，它的内圈是每分钟 100 秒，而在外圈则有每小时 60 秒，这样可以帮你进行换算。
That's really nice. Yeah, so it's like the inside, you have like Roman numerals one through 10 and one through 100. And then the outside, you have up to 24. So you have the 24 hour clock in the outside and the 10 hour clock on the inside. And the idea was you can look at it and see both at the same time. So it's kind of this nicely designed object.
这真的很不错。是的，就像在内圈，你有从 1 到 10 的罗马数字，还有 1 到 100。而在外圈，数字一直到 24。所以外圈是 24 小时制的时钟，内圈则是 10 小时制的时钟。这样设计的理念是，你可以看一眼就同时看到这两种时间。所以它算是一个设计得很巧妙的物品。
It's very elegant, I think. It's clever. It's complex, but the complexities were reason. So it's a transitional piece. So, you know, given that you had these nice little clocks sent out to people to help them convert, what was the resistance like? Yeah, I mean, just imagine completely switching your understanding of time in a day. I mean, the issues are kind of exactly what you'd expect. Like, there's international trade. So you can't really sync up with other countries that are using a completely different way of time keeping, right?
我觉得它非常优雅。很巧妙。它很复杂，但这种复杂性是有理由的。所以它是一个过渡时期的产物。那么，鉴于你们把这些精美的小时钟发给人们来帮他们换算，当时的阻力有多大呢？是的，我是说，想象一下完全颠覆你对一天中时间的理解。我的意思是，问题基本上就是你所预料的那样。比如，有国际贸易。所以你根本无法与那些使用完全不同计时方式的其他国家保持同步，对吧？
Second, it's annoying, you know, it's expensive to replace all the clocks, even if you have these nice, elegant, you know, two-faced clocks. And I mean, the biggest thing is like, people are stubborn about it, right? Like, in this system, a decimal hour would be the equivalent of two hours and 24 minutes. Yeah, that does not feel natural. No, I mean, it's like, it's like the length of a new Hollywood movie in these days. Like the, like the shortest Marvel movie would be an hour. It would be, it would be one hour long.
其次，这很烦人，你知道的，替换所有的时钟成本很高，哪怕你拥有这些设计精美、拥有双表盘的时钟。我的意思是，最重要的一点是，人们在这方面很顽固，对吧？在这个系统中，一个十进制的小时相当于我们现在的 2 小时 24 分钟。是的，这感觉一点也不自然。不，我的意思是，这就像是，这就像现在一部好莱坞新电影的长度。比如，最短的漫威电影也会是一个小时。它会是，它会是一个小时长。
Well, it's not, the way I'd like to think about it, it's somewhere between Barbie and Oppenheimer. It's almost the difference between the two films. But that's a huge shift, right? Like, it's going to be this expensive time-consuming thing, just a really big pain in the ass. And also there were like no obvious benefits to changing it. Like the 12-hour, 24-hour system worked just fine. So people were not eager to try a new thing
好吧，这不对，我倾向于认为它介于《芭比》和《奥本海默》之间。这几乎就是这两部电影之间的时长差。但这是一个巨大的转变，对吧？这会是一件既昂贵又耗时的事情，简直是个巨大的麻烦。而且这样做也没有任何显而易见的好处。像 12 小时制、24 小时制这样的系统运行得非常好。所以人们并不渴望去尝试一个新事物
just for the sake of it. So when did the French abandon it? So they had the calendar, right? They had the calendar with 10-day weeks and all that. That actually lasted into the 19th century, that lasted for a few years. But the 10-hour day, that did not really take off and that was actually abandoned after less than two years. And so did that kill the whole idea of decimal time?
仅仅是为了尝鲜。那么法国人是什么时候放弃它的呢？所以他们有日历，对吧？他们有那个 10 天一周的日历以及所有那些东西。那个实际上一直持续到了 19 世纪，持续了好几年。但是 10 小时制的一天，并没有真正流行起来，在不到两年的时间里就被废弃了。那么这是否彻底扼杀了十进制时间的想法呢？
It seems like we always have these sort of moments where people reassess and try to have a more rational, like, counting system and measurement system and even time system. So there have been proposals over the years to reintroduce decimal time. At a conference, a mathematician will be like, oh, this is an interesting idea. Let's think about it. But the most high profile version of this was by the Swiss company Swatch in 1998. So as a publicity stunt, they introduced an idea they called internet time that would divide up the day into 1,000 swatch beats, so you know, decimalization divided by 10.
似乎我们总是有这样的时刻：人们会重新评估，试图建立一个更加理性的计数系统、计量系统甚至是时间系统。因此，多年来一直有人提出重新引入十进制时间的提案。在某个会议上，某个数学家会说，哦，这是个有趣的想法。让我们考虑一下。但其中最高调的一次是由瑞士手表制造商斯沃琪（Swatch）在 1998 年提出的。作为一次宣传噱头，他们引入了一个名为“互联网时间”（internet time）的概念，将一天划分为 1000 个斯沃琪节拍（beats），你看，这就是十进制，也就是除以 10。
And this was actually to promote a digital watch that they were rolling out. And like it wasn't a serious proposal, but it's actually still up on their website, if you look for it. Oh, wow. Ultimately, like I have been thinking a lot about this. And maybe there is a good argument for using base 10 for our timekeeping. 10 hours, 100 minutes, it's very clean, it's very rational, but I don't think this proposal
这其实是为了推广他们当时正在推出的一款数码手表。虽然这不是一个严肃的提案，但如果你去搜一下，它其实至今仍然挂在他们的官网上。哦，哇。归根结底，我一直在深入思考这件事。也许为我们的计时系统采用以 10 为基数确实有很好的论据。10 小时，100 分钟，非常干净利落，非常理性，但我认为这个提案
takes into account how stubborn people are, and also the fact that humans just don't work that way. We are not clean and rational beings. We're going to force our world of mechanics and digitalization and logical thinking upon poor little humans who are illogical, they don't think logically, they have emotions and all that. And no wonder it didn't catch on because logic is wonderful for the intellectuals who live in their little towers. But not for the everyday person who wants to come on to buy high-go to friends.
没有考虑到人类是多么顽固，以及人类根本不是那样运作的事实。我们并不是干净又理性的生物。我们要把我们的机械化、数字化和逻辑思维的世界强加给可怜的小人类，而人类却是不理性的，他们不按逻辑思考，他们有情绪等等。难怪它没有流行起来，因为逻辑对于住在高塔里的知识分子来说是美妙的。但对于那些只想来买高档货、去法国的朋友的普通人来说却并非如此。
Do they behave logically? No, we have these wonderful breakfasts. They know what's important, it was not important, they enjoy life. Yes, that sounds very true and very sort of our experience with design is like, you can have big lofty ideas, but in the end when it's sort of drafted
他们行为符合逻辑吗？不，我们有这些美妙的早餐。他们知道什么重要，什么不重要，他们享受生活。是的，这听起来非常真实，也很符合我们对设计的体验，那就是：你可以有宏大崇高的想法，但最终当它被落实到
on our silly and capricious world, it just does not work. Yeah, exactly right. Thanks you for always bringing us up, you know, silly and kind of profound ideas all in one package. Of course, thanks Roman, and it's my pleasure. I just wanted to say before we go a big thank you to Don Norman He has a new book that just came out earlier this year called Design for a Better World. And I will say, it is very much worth your time. Okay, all about it.
我们这个傻气而反复无常的世界中时，它就是行不通。是的，完全正确。谢谢你总是给我们带来这些既傻气又深刻、两者兼具的想法。当然，谢谢罗曼，这是我的荣幸。我只想在离开前对唐·诺曼表示衷心的感谢。他今年早些时候刚出了一本新书，叫做《为更美好的世界而设计》（Design for a Better World）。我要说的是，这本书非常值得你花时间阅读。好的，全部了解。
Okay, sounds good. Thanks Chris. Thanks Robin. So I'm in the studio with Digital Director and 99% Invisible City co-author Kurt Colstad Hey Kurt! Hey Roman, how's it going? It's good, it's our favorite time of the year, it's many stories time, what many stories do you have for us?
好的，听起来不错。谢谢克里斯。谢谢罗曼。我现在和数字总监兼《99% Invisible City》的合著者库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）在录音室里。嘿，库尔特！嘿，罗曼，最近怎么样？很好，这是我们一年中最喜欢的时光，也就是迷你故事时间，你给我们带来了什么迷你故事？
So as you know, I got my graduate degree in architecture, but I have something for you that you might not know in common with some of the most famous architects in modern history, including the Corbusier and Frank Lloyd Wright, which is that even with my degree, I was never qualified to actually strictly speaking be a practicing architect. Well, why would probably hope that for you, you wouldn't be a practicing architect. Well, why would probably hope that for you, you wouldn't be a practicing architect without maybe some licensing or qualifications beyond your degree, but I did not know that
如你所知，我的建筑学研究生学位，但我有一件事要告诉你，你可能不知道我和现代历史上一些最著名的建筑师（包括勒·柯布西耶和弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特）有一个共同点，那就是尽管我拥有学位，但严格来说，我从来没有资格成为一名真正执业的建筑师。好吧，人们大概会希望你这样，如果没有超出你学位的某种执照或资格，你就不会成为一名执业建筑师。好吧，人们大概会希望你这样，如果没有超出你学位的某种执照或资格，你就不该成为一名执业建筑师，但我确实不知道
about Kaboose A or Frank Lloyd Wright. Yeah, all right. There's accreditation and tests you have to take, but neither right nor corbou sat for their exam. Okay, so they didn't take the test or whatever, but like, did they actually study architecture? Yeah, not exactly so much that either, because the corbousee studied decorative arts
关于柯布西耶或弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的这一点。是的，没错。有认证和必须通过的考试，但赖特和柯布西耶都没有参加过他们的考试。好吧，所以他们没参加考试什么的，但是——他们真的学过建筑学吗？是的，其实也不是很算，因为柯布西耶学的是装饰艺术，
and right did take some engineering classes, but that was about it. Wow, I mean, I guess I read that about Franklin Wright, but I just cannot believe that he wasn't technically qualified to be an architect. Yeah, right. I mean, he's a guy who, even the AIA said, like, is the greatest American architect,
而赖特确实上过一些工程课，但也仅此而已。哇，我的意思是，我好像读到过关于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的这件事，但我实在无法相信他居然在技术上没有资格成为一名建筑师。对吧。我的意思是，他可是连美国建筑师协会（AIA）都称赞为“有史以来最伟大的美国建筑师”的人，
and here he is, not really qualified to be an architect. And that wasn't that uncommon. Some designers don't want to study for that test or get the prerequisite work requirements or meet those continuing Ed requirements. And learning on the job as an apprentice used to be a much more common path into architectural design. But to legally call yourself an architect, you have to jump through the legal hoops.
而他居然没有真正具备建筑师的资格。这其实并不罕见。有些设计师不想为那个考试去学习，或者不想去满足那些先决的工作要求或继续教育要求。作为学徒在工作中边干边学，曾经是进入建筑设计领域更常见的一条途径。但要在法律上称自己为建筑师，你必须跨过这些法律门槛。
Yeah. And that makes sense to me because you can't have just unlicensed non-architects out there designing buildings. That's whatever. You know, like, it would make me never want to go into a building again if I thought about this too deeply. So totally, right? Yeah. And there are workarounds. For one thing, if a building is small enough, it might not need an architect. Most houses don't. But big buildings, yeah, they do. And in some cases, like this one firm I worked at out of college, there may be only a few licensed architects
是的。这对我来说说得通，因为你总不能让无证的非建筑师在那里设计建筑物。那太……你知道的，如果我深入去想这件事，它会让我再也不想走进任何一栋建筑里。完全是这样，对吧？是的。而且也有一些变通办法。一方面，如果一栋建筑足够小，它可能就不需要建筑师。大多数房子都不需要。但大建筑，是的，它们需要。在某些情况下，就像我大学毕业后工作过的那家公司，员工中可能只有少数几位是有执照的建筑师，
on staff, and part of their job is to look at and sign off on official drawings made by other designers. But there is this one famous architect, well, non-architect, who is a personal favorite designer of mine, who also didn't have a degree, and on top of that, he eventually got into trouble for practicing without one. And his name was Carlos Scarpa,
而他们工作的一部分就是审核并签署其他设计师绘制的官方图纸。但确实有这么一位著名的建筑师——或者说非建筑师，他是我个人非常喜欢的设计师，他也没有学位，不仅如此，他最终还因为无证执业而惹上了麻烦。他的名字叫卡洛·斯卡帕（Carlo Scarpa），
and he was a 20th century Italian designer who, despite his lack of credentials, nonetheless worked in one of the richest, historical, urban environments in the world, his hometown of Venice. Oh, I love Venice. I just went to Venice for the world, his hometown of Venice. Oh, I love Venice. I just went to Venice for the first time. It's amazing.
他是一位 20 世纪的意大利设计师，尽管他缺乏资质，却依然在世界上最富丽堂皇、充满历史底蕴的城市环境之一——他的家乡威尼斯——工作。哦，我爱威尼斯。我刚去过威尼斯。世界，他的家乡威尼斯。哦，我爱威尼斯。我刚刚第一次去了威尼斯。太神奇了。
It does look like maybe non-architects put Venice together. Totally, right? Yeah, very much a-a-created over time. And so, yeah, and he's sort of like this all-world tour, a Louis Con figure, who, like, he was a modernist, but more of a regional modernist, and he he was a modernist, but more of a regional modernist, and he wasn't a modernist in the sense of white walls and flat surfaces that you think of when you think of that era of design, he was known for adding his own creative and often
看起来威尼斯还真可能是由非建筑师拼凑起来的。完全是这样，对吧？是的，它在很大程度上是在漫长岁月中逐渐形成的。所以，是的，他有点像是一位全能的大师、路易·康式的人物，他是一位现代主义者，但更倾向于区域现代主义，而且他
quite bold and eccentric design details to this rich historical context. And his work on historical buildings was arguably very subjective. It was loaded with his own personal style, his own interpretations. Okay, so describe a little bit more of what that looks like. Well, Scarpa was known for taking a lot of creative liberties. Like he'd peel back parts of walls and floors to create these virtual windows into the past.
在那种充满历史底蕴的环境中，以加入自己具有创造力且通常相当大胆、古怪的设计细节而闻名。他在历史建筑上的作品可以说是非常主观的。里面充斥着他个人的风格和独特的诠释。好吧，再多描述一点这看起来是什么样的。嗯，斯卡帕以享有极大的创作自由而闻名。比如他会剥开墙壁和地板的一部分，在过去与现在之间创造出这些虚拟的“窗户”。
And in something like a museum renovation, for example, he wouldn't just put up blank white walls, like you might picture in like a normal museum, he'd take, say, a sculpture and say, hey, let's put this on a 10 foot pedestal. And I'll design that too. Oh, and that'll paint the wall behind it in this particular color, which I'll pick,
比如在博物馆翻修之类的项目中，他不会只是粉刷几面空白的白墙，就像你在普通博物馆里可能想象的那样，他会拿出一尊雕塑然后说：“嘿，我们把它放在一个 10 英尺高的基座上吧。这个基座我也来设计。”哦，还要把背后的墙刷成我精心挑选的这种特定颜色，
and it'll face in this direction with the sunlight coming in this way and so on. So he really like controlled that experience and much like our friends, the Corbusier and right. This guy with all of his creativity, all of his great ideas, didn't have a license, but he was at least a little closer than they were in some ways for what it's worth. What do you mean by that?
然后让它朝向这个方向，阳光从这边照进来，诸如此类。所以他真的掌控了那种体验，就像我们的朋友柯布西耶和赖特一样。这个充满创造力、满脑子伟大想法的家伙，居然没有执照，不过不管怎么说，他在某些方面至少比那两人更接近合法一点。你这话是什么意思？
Well, he was educated in architecture at the Venice Academy of Fine Arts, but then he, like me, stopped short of actually taking the exam. You know, the one that would have secured him a license to become a legally practicing architect. So despite at least having some kind of the right degree, he managed to run a foul of the law, and at one point, after he'd been designing buildings for years, he was sued by the Venice Order of Architects, poor practicing architecture without a license. Wow, okay, that seems like a big deal, like presumably, like, he wouldn't be able
嗯，他在威尼斯美术学院接受过建筑学教育，但他跟我一样，在真正参加考试前就停下了。你知道的，就是那场能为他赢得执照、成为合法执业建筑师的考试。所以尽管他至少拥有某种正确的学位，他还是设法触犯了法律。在设计了多年建筑后的某个时期，他被威尼斯建筑师协会起诉，罪名是无证非法执业。哇，好吧，这听起来像是一件大事。想必如果他被判有罪或者类似的话，他就再也不能
to build buildings anymore of that if he was found guilty or something like that. Like his professional life was on the line. Yeah, pretty high stakes, right? Yeah. But then something remarkable happened. As the story goes, when the case wound up in front of the judge, it was in a courtroom that Scarpa himself had designed. Right. And you know, it sounds really far-fetched, but if you think about it, I mean, finish isn't that big of a city, right? That's not it.
建造建筑物了。他的职业生涯正悬于一线。是的，风险确实非常高，对吧？是的。但随后发生了非同寻常的事情。据故事所说，当案件呈交到法官面前时，开庭的法庭本身居然就是斯卡帕亲自设计的。没错。你知道的，这听起来太离谱了，但如果你仔细想想，威尼斯其实也不是个很大的城市，对吧？不是这样的。
Oh, it's not possible. So, okay, so describe this courtroom domain. This is amazing. The thing is, it wasn't grand or ostentatious, but it was executed with a lot of care for details, which is really what Scarpa was all about. Here, check it out. Okay, let me take a look at this thing.
哦，这是不可能的。所以，好吧，给我们描述一下这个法庭的内景吧。这太神奇了。重点是，它既不宏伟也不显山露水，但它的细节处理得极其精细，而这正是斯卡帕的拿手好戏。来吧，看一看。好吧，让我来看看这个东西。
Yes, okay, so what I see here is it is pretty modern. It doesn't have like the high ceilings of a lot of like Italian architecture does. It's lots of wood, lots of straight lines. It looks like the office of a minstead tree modern building. It's it's it's lovely. Yeah, yeah. And it's all about like it's not too over the top, right? Yeah, it is pretty elegant and simple overall with these laminated wood seats and desks with expressive joinery, but it's the little things as usual where his design stand out, like
是的，好吧，我在这里看到的是它相当现代。它没有许多意大利建筑那种高高的天花板。这里有大量的木材，大量的直线。它看起来像是一座现代主义建筑内部的办公室。它非常可爱。是的，是的。而且它的关键在于它并不是过于夸张，对吧？是的，总体来说相当优雅和简朴，配有层压木座椅和带有表现力细木工艺的桌子，但一如既往，正是那些微小之处让他的设计脱颖而出，比如
the door knobs at the entryway, which are geometric and complex, sort of like or neat little modernist sculptures. And like, say, Alvarale tale, a lot of attention is paid to where people will touch the design, right? Like the wood where you run your fingers along the chair or the banister. So set this scene for me. He's in court trying to defend himself for practicing architecture without a license. He ends up being tried in a room that he designed, sitting there with a judge. He's sitting in the chair. He designed with its nice joinery and all. What happens? Well, apparently he didn't have to do a lot of work to defend himself because the judge
入口处的门把手，它们几何形状复杂，有点像精致的小型现代主义雕塑。就像阿尔瓦·阿尔托一样，很多心思都花在了人们会用手触摸设计的地方，对吧？比如你在椅子或楼梯扶手上滑过手指的那些木头。所以，帮我还原一下当时的情景。他正站在法庭上为自己无证执业的行为进行辩护。结果他是在一间自己设计的房间里受审，和法官坐在一起。他坐在自己设计的、带有精美细木工艺的椅子上。接下来发生了什么？嗯，显然他不需要费太多力气去为自己辩护，因为法官
sort of sat there and looked around the room and reckoned that Skarp seemed like a pretty good architect as far as he could tell. And so he dismissed the case. That's amazing. Right? He's like exhibit A and the adjusters, broadly. And to add to that, I read that the lawyer who was representing Scarpa was also so impressed that he ended up hiring Scarpa to design his own house too. That's amazing. Okay, so so he wins because of the great example that he's sitting in and he keeps practicing architecture like what what does he end up doing after that? So he kept up this sort of signature creativity in this orientation towards detail
就那样坐在那里，环顾四周的房间，心想从他所能看到的来看，斯卡帕似乎是个相当不错的建筑师。于是法官驳回了起诉。这太神奇了。对吧？这就好比他是把“展品 A”直接搬到了法官眼皮底下。不仅如此，我还听说代表斯卡帕出庭的律师也对他的设计印象深刻，最后竟然也雇佣斯卡帕来为他设计自己的房子。太惊人了。好吧，所以他因为自己正坐在其中的这个伟大范例而赢得了官司，然后他继续从事建筑设计——他后来到底做了什么？所以他一直保持着这种标志性的创造力、对细节的关注
and this kind of quirky charm even up until he died at the age of 72. And I kind of after as well, even after he died. Oh, what do you mean by after he died? Well, he designed his own burial plot, for example, and he incorporated this kind of drainage hole into the lid of the coffin cover. And visitors were encouraged to come share a glass of wine with him after he had passed away. You know, by basically pouring one down into this drink and giving him a drink and then having their own drink. And in any case, I just think it's really charming like how he was really creative up to and through the end. That's amazing. Right? I like this guy. Yeah, he is fantastic.
以及这种古怪的魅力，一直持续到他 72 岁去世。甚至在他去世之后也是如此。哦，你指的去世之后是什么意思？嗯，例如，他设计了自己的墓地，并在棺木盖的盖子上结合了这种排水孔。他鼓励参观者在他去世后去和他共饮一杯酒。你知道的，基本上就是把酒倒进这个饮酒孔里敬他一杯，然后他们自己也喝一杯。无论如何，我只是觉得这真的很迷人，他直到生命的尽头以及超越生死都充满了创造力。这太神奇了。对吧？我喜欢这家伙。是的，他太棒了。
I mean, if you're ever in Venice, you should really go and pour one out for the guy. Yeah, or pour one on him, I guess. Yeah, pour one on him as it were. That's amazing. I love it. I love it. Well, this is such a great story. Thank you so much, Kurt.
我的意思是，如果你有机会去威尼斯，你真的应该去为这家伙敬上一杯酒。是的，或者把酒倒在他身上，我猜。是的，就像人们常说的，把酒倒在他身上。这太神奇了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，这是一个如此棒的故事。非常感谢你，库尔特。
Thank you, Roman. So I'm here with Delaney Hall. Hey Delaney, what's your mini story? Hey Roman, so recently Kurt was telling me about a phenomenon called ghost kitchens. I had never heard of this before. And it kind of exploded my whole idea about what a restaurant even is in this time. And it was very confusing experience researching these things. And so that's what I'd like to talk with you about today. Okay, okay. Let's start with what you found. Like what is a ghost kitchen? So ghost kitchens have a few names. They're sometimes known as dark kitchens or virtual kitchens, cloud kitchens. And they're a relatively new trend
谢谢罗曼。我现在和德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）在一起。嘿，德兰妮，你的迷你故事是什么？嘿，罗曼，最近库尔特跟我讲了一个叫做“幽灵厨房”（ghost kitchens）的现象。我以前从来没听说过这个。它彻底颠覆了我对在这个时代“餐馆究竟是什么”的整个看法。研究这些东西是一段非常让人困惑的经历。所以这就是我今天想跟你聊聊的话题。好吧，好吧。我们从你发现的情况开始。到底什么是幽灵厨房？幽灵厨房有好几个名字。它们有时被称为暗黑厨房（dark kitchens）、虚拟厨房（virtual kitchens）或云厨房（cloud kitchens）。它们是餐饮业中一个相对较新的趋势，
in the restaurant industry that seem to really take off during the pandemic. That was because of the popularity of delivery services like DoorDash and UberEats. And the basic idea is that they are kitchens that specialize in delivery only. They do not have a storefront, they do not have servers, they do not have a place, you can walk in and sit down, they only sell food through delivery apps. And I can totally see why this cropped up during the pandemic because the first like hardest thing to do in this world is to run a restaurant with a storefront and then all
似乎在疫情期间真正火了起来。这是因为 DoorDash 和 UberEats 等外卖服务的普及。其基本理念是，这些厨房专门从事仅限外卖的业务。它们没有店面，没有服务员，也没有供你走进去坐下来的地方，它们只通过外卖应用程序出售食物。我完全能理解为什么这会在疫情期间涌现，因为在这个世界上开一家有实体店面的餐馆本来就是最难的事情之一，然后突然之间你的客源全都没了，因为出于防疫原因你不能把他们塞满店里，但人们仍然需要吃饭，所以他们只能做外卖；如果吃的是外卖，谁会在乎它是不是来自一家有实体店面的餐馆呢。是的，这里面完全存在经济逻辑。但它们是如何运作的？你该如何搭建一个？幽灵厨房有好几种不同的类型。其中一种是为一大堆不同的、所谓的“餐馆”制作食物的厨房，
of a sudden your crowds are gone because you can't pack them in there because of COVID, but still people need to eat and so they are only doing delivery and if you're being delivered food, who cares if it's from a restaurant with a storefront or not. Yeah, there is totally an economic logic to it. But how do they work? How do you set one up? So there are a few different types of ghost kitchens. One type is a kitchen that makes food for a bunch of different quote unquote restaurants
而这些餐馆都有着各自不同的身份和名字。这些餐馆基本上只是把它们的数字招牌挂在 DoorDash 或 UberEats 等服务上。它们看起来可能是不同的餐馆，但现实是它们的食物全都是在同一个幽灵厨房里烹制的。这非常有趣。可能会有大量只做外卖的餐馆，
that all have different identities and names. And those restaurants are basically hanging their digital shingle out on services like DoorDash or UberEats. And they might appear to be different restaurants, but the reality is that all of their food is cooked in the same ghost kitchen. And it's pretty interesting. There can be a lot of delivery only restaurants
但它们实际上全都属于同一个幽灵厨房运营实体。举个例子，我看了埃迪·伯巴克（Eddie Burback）制作的一个视频。他是一位喜剧演员兼 YouTuber，我必须说，他进行了可以说是出人意料的深入调查，揭秘了幽灵厨房。他基本上是扫描了外卖应用程序，寻找洛杉矶那些登记地址完全相同的餐馆。结果他发现竟然有多达 44 家不同的餐馆共享同一个地址，
that are all actually part of the same ghost kitchen operation. So as an example, I watched this video by Eddie Burback. He's a comedian and a YouTuber who did, I have to say, this is surprisingly deep dive investigation into ghost kitchens. And he basically scanned delivery apps looking for restaurants in LA that all listed the same address. And he found that there were a whopping 44 different restaurants that all shared the same location,
这绝对是一个明显的迹象，表明你遇到的是幽灵厨房。哇。埃迪·伯巴克还发现了另一个奇怪的事情，那就是这些外卖应用程序往往会给人一种“选择非常丰富”的感觉。比如有各种各样不同的标志和餐馆名称。但有趣的是，有时这些地方做出来的食物好像全都是一样的。他发现这一点的原因是，埃迪开始查看那些标榜来自不同餐馆、但实际上位于同一地址的菜单项。
which is a real tip off that you're dealing with the Ghost Kitchens. Wow. And there was this other curious thing that Eddie Burback discovered, which is that these delivery apps, they often give the feeling of a lot of variety. Like there's lots of different logos and restaurant names. But the funny thing is that sometimes those places all seem to be making the same food. And the way he discovered this is that Eddie started looking at the menu items from supposedly different restaurants that were all based at the same location.
他发现它们似乎都有完全相同的“啤酒面糊鳕鱼三明治”。比如，图片完全一样，赞美之词完全一样，描述也完全一样：啤酒面糊北大西洋鳕鱼、凉拌卷心菜（红白卷心菜）、
And he found that they all seem to have the exact same beer battered cod sandwich. Like, it's all the same picture. It's all the same praise, the exact same description, which is a beer battered, North Atlantic cod, Slaw, Red and White cabbage,
柠檬、香草蒜泥蛋黄酱（aioli）以及布里欧修面包（brioche bun）。以及布里欧修面包。所以我查看了同一地址上的另一个显而易见的选择——日落海滩炸鱼薯条（Sunset Beach Fish and Chips），你瞧瞧这是什么？那里有一个售价 16.95 美元的啤酒面糊鳕鱼三明治，它也是啤酒面糊北大西洋鳕鱼、凉拌卷心菜、红白卷心菜、柠檬、香草蒜泥蛋黄酱和布里欧修面包。有趣！Uber Eats 上的两家独立餐馆
Lemon, Urb, Aole, and a Brioche bun. And a Brioche bun. So I looked at another obvious choice at the same address, at a sunset beach fish and chips, and would you look at that? There's a beer-battered con sandwich for 1695 that is a beer-battered North Atlantic cod, slaw, red and white cabbage, lemon, herb-eoli, and a brioche bun. Interesting! Two separate restaurants on Uber Eats
看起来像是完全独立的业务，却在以相同的价格、相同的描述销售相同的商品。于是我又查看了另一个售价 16.95 美元、带有啤酒面糊鳕鱼的三明治店，描述一模一样。接着我又看了另一家。他发现，这种现象一次又一次地出现。于是埃迪最终从据称是 9 家不同的餐馆订购了 9 个看起来完全相同的鳕鱼三明治，但它们其实全都在同一个地址制作。这太诡异了。太诡异了。这让人不禁好奇，为什么单一的幽灵厨房要营销完全相同的三明治，却让它看起来像是来自所有这些不同的餐馆呢，对吧？
appearing to be completely separate businesses selling the same item with the same description for the same price. So I looked at another place that had a beard-battered cot for $16.95, same description. And I looked at another place. And he finds that, like, again and again. And so Eddie ends up ordering nine seemingly identical cod sandwiches from supposedly nine different restaurants, but they're all based at the same location. That is very weird. So weird. And it makes you wonder why a single ghost kitchen would market the exact same sandwich, but make it appear to come from all these different restaurants, right?
在我看来比较合理的解释是，你使用这些应用程序的方式，通常是进入一家餐馆并去浏览它。这并不是说你一定是在寻找一个鳕鱼三明治，然后在不同的餐馆之间进行比较。这就好像你身处一家餐馆内部在做决定一样。所以，如果他们想卖那个鳕鱼三明治，而且他们手里有大量的鳕鱼三明治可供出售，那么把它塞进尽可能多的、看起来合适的餐馆里，就说得通了。9 家似乎有点太多了。是的，我觉得整件事给我一种“用海量信息淹没这个领域”的感觉。就像，完全是这样。
The way that it makes sense to me is that the way you use those apps, you sort of go into a restaurant and you explore it. It's not like you're necessarily looking for a cod sandwich and then you're comparing across restaurants. Almost like you're in a restaurant itself trying to decide. And so if they want to sell that cod sandwich and they have lots of cod sandwiches available to be sold, it makes sense to put them in, you know, as many restaurants as it seems appropriate. Nine seems excessive. Yeah, I think the whole thing has a kind of flood the zone feeling to me. Like, yeah, totally.
如果有人想吃鳕鱼三明治，只要你提供同款三明治的次数达到 9 次，他们从你厨房挑选鳕鱼三明治的几率就会上升。所以，是的，这些餐馆有一种特质，感觉带有某种科技优化的氛围。就好像他们正试图对这些外卖应用程序进行 SEO 骇客攻击一样。而且，这并不令人意外，因为其中许多幽灵厨房都是由科技初创公司拥有的。哦，原来如此。它们其实并不是某种新型餐馆。它们实际上只是另一种形式的科技。是的。在很多方面，你可以找到
If someone's wanting a cod sandwich, the chance of them picking a cod sandwich from your kitchen goes up if you're offering the same sandwich, but nine times. And so, yeah, there's just a quality of these restaurants that feels like it has sort of tech optimization vibes. It's like they're trying to SEO hack these delivery apps. And, you know, that's not surprising because many of these ghost kitchens are owned by tech startups. Oh, okay. They're not actually like some new form of restaurant. They really are just another form of tech. Yeah. And in a lot of ways, like, I think you can find
幽灵厨房的个别老板，但其中也涉及与科技行业有着深厚联系的大玩家。比如 Uber 的前首席执行官特拉维斯·卡兰尼克（Travis Kalanick）一直在致力于 CloudKitchens，这是一个幽灵厨房初创公司。或者还有 Reef Technology，一家包含多品牌厨房的初创公司。
an individual owner of ghost kitchens, but there are big players involved with deep connections to the tech industry. So Travis Kalanick, the former chief executive of Uber, has been working on cloud kitchens, which is a ghost kitchen startup. Or there's also reef technology, a startup that includes multi brand kitchens.
这非常符合“餐饮遇见科技”的世界。这种趋势也正在以有趣的方式与传统的实体餐馆发生交集。所以还有另一种幽灵厨房我要告诉你。它实际上是在现有的实体餐馆里运营的。好的，跟我多说说那些。
This is very much a world where restaurants meet tech. And this trend is also intersecting with traditional brick and mortar restaurants in interesting ways. So there's another type of ghost kitchen I'll tell you about. And it actually runs out of existing restaurants. Okay, tell me more about those. So what's happened is that some of the most popular chain restaurants out there, and these are places with actual restaurants you can eat in, they've decided to cash in on this trend. And what some of them have done is they've created
情况是这样的：一些最受欢迎的连锁餐厅——也就是那些你可以进去就餐的实体餐厅——它们决定乘上这股潮流来分一杯羹。它们中的一些人所做的事情是，创造了
new delivery only restaurant brands that they are running out of their existing chain kitchens. restaurant brands that they are running out of their existing chain kitchen. But it is not always clear to consumers that the delivery only brand is affiliated with that chain. So I thought to show you like how confusing this can be that it might be fun to give you a little quiz. Are you down for that? Totally. I'm going to do that. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to name the Ghost Kitchen Identity. And then I want you to try and guess which major restaurant chain runs it. Okay. Okay. So the first Ghost Kitchen brand is Pascuali's pizza and wings. Which major chain do you think runs it? Um, I'm gonna say dominoes. It's good guess. That is that is not the answer. That was a good guess.
全新的、仅限外卖的餐厅品牌，而这些品牌是在它们现有的连锁店厨房里运营的。但对于消费者来说，这个仅限外卖的品牌是否隶属于该连锁店并不总是那么清晰。我想向大家展示一下这到底能有多混乱，所以玩一个小测验可能会很有趣。你们有兴趣吗？当然。我要这么做。所以我要做的是，我会说出一个幽灵厨房的身份。然后我想让你们猜猜是哪家大型连锁餐厅在运营它。好的。好的。所以第一个幽灵厨房品牌是帕斯夸利比萨和鸡翅（Pascuali's pizza and wings）。你认为哪家大连锁店在经营它？嗯，我猜是达美乐（Domino's）。猜得很好。但答案不是这个。这是一个很好的猜测。
The answer is Chuck E. Cheese. Oh, no. Oh, my. Isn't that so clever? Because if you went on a delivery app like you rolling in Mars and you were looking for pizza, would you order it from Chuck E.G. No way. Would you perhaps order it from Pascualis? It's certainly infinitely more possible than me ordering from Chuck E.G. Oh, this is great. It, this is funny. Have another one. Yes, yes, I do. Okay. So the next ghost kitchen brand is called pardon my cheese steak, which major chain runs pardon my cheese steak. Pardon my cheese steak. I don't know of any major chain that sells cheese steaks. This must be like a, wow.
答案是查奇芝士（Chuck E. Cheese）。哦，不。天哪。这难道不是很聪明吗？因为如果你上了像 Uber Eats 这样的外卖应用，就像罗曼·马尔斯一样，如果你想找比萨，你会从查奇芝士订购吗？绝不可能。你或许会从帕斯夸利订购吧？这绝对比我从查奇芝士订购的可能性要高出无数倍。哦，太棒了。这太搞笑了。再来一个。好的，好的，我来。好的。所以下一个幽灵厨房品牌的名称叫做“原谅我的芝士牛排”（Pardon My Cheesesteak），哪家大连锁店在运营“原谅我的芝士牛排”呢？原谅我的芝士牛排。我不知道有哪家大连锁店卖芝士牛排。这一定是个，哇。
Like Arbis? No, it is actually IHOP, the international house of pancakes. Whoa, okay. Yes. Wow. And it is not the only ghost kitchen brand that IHOP runs. They also do thrilled cheese, super mega dilla, and tender fix.
比如阿尔比（Arby's）？不，实际上是 IHOP（国际煎饼屋，International House of Pancakes）。哇，好吧。是的。哇。而且这还不是 IHOP 运营的唯一一个幽灵厨房品牌。他们还经营着“激动人心的芝士”（Thrilled Cheese）、“超级巨无霸墨西哥烤饼”（Super Mega Dilla）和“嫩肉专修”（Tender Fix）。
Wow. I am totally shocked by all of this. This is amazing to me. It's like this opportunity for chain restaurants that have a very fixed identity. It allows them to kind of come up with these surprising alter egos. It's like a chance to reach radically different markets
哇。我对这一切感到彻底震惊。这对我来说太神奇了。这就像是为那些拥有非常固定身份的连锁餐厅提供了一个机会。它让他们能够推出这些令人惊奇的“分身”。这就像是一个机会，去接触到
than the ones that you might actually reach through your brick and mortar restaurant. So you can essentially disguise who's behind a certain operation and all the connotations of a place like I have, you know? And all the animatronic robots. And you can hide those fine, the curtain. Yeah. Okay, so so far we've covered Ghost Kitchens robots and you can hide those fine the curtain.
那些你通过实体餐厅可能根本无法接触到的、截然不同的市场。所以你基本上可以伪装是谁在某个业务背后，以及掩盖像 IHOP 这样地方的所有既定印象，你知道吗？还有那些电子动画机器人。你可以把它们藏在幕后。好吧。所以到目前为止，我们已经讨论了幽灵厨房
Yeah. Okay, so so far we've covered Ghost Kitchens operating multiple delivery only brands out of one commercial space. And we've covered big restaurant chains who've developed these delivery only alter egos, but there's one last example of a Ghost K kitchen that I wanted to share with you because this is the one that sort of like broke my brain. I learned about this one from that Eddie Burback video I mentioned. And are you familiar with Mr. Beast, the YouTuber?
在一个商业空间里运营多个仅限外卖的品牌。我们还讨论了开发了这些仅限外卖分身的大型连锁餐厅，但还有一个关于幽灵厨房的最后例子我想和大家分享，因为这就是那个彻底颠覆我认知的例子。我是从我提到的那个埃迪·伯巴克视频里了解到这一点的。你对“野兽先生”（Mr. Beast，知名 YouTuber）熟悉吗？
I'm familiar with the name Mr. Beast. I've never seen a Mr. Beast video, but I mentioned to my kids at some point something about Mr. Beast. I've never seen a Mr. Beast video, but I mentioned to my kids at some point, something about Mr. Beast, and they were completely just jaw on the floor that I'd never really heard of or seen Mr. Beast or what Mr. Beast was about. For those who aren't aware, he is a hugely popular YouTuber. He's known for doing over-the-top stunts and charity stuff, he'll get like 200 million views on a video called, I ate the world's largest slice of pizza. This is the largest slice of pizza in the entire world. Look how long it is.
我对“野兽先生”这个名字很熟悉。我从来没看过“野兽先生”的视频，但我曾在某个时候向我的孩子们提起过关于“野兽先生”的事。我从来没看过“野兽先生”的视频，但我曾在某个时候向我的孩子们提起过关于“野兽先生”的事，他们当时简直惊掉下巴，因为我居然从来没听说过、也没看过“野兽先生”，或者不知道“野兽先生”是做什么的。对于那些不知道的人来说，他是一个极受欢迎的 YouTuber。他以拍摄夸张的特技和慈善活动而闻名，他的一条名为《我吃了世界上最大的比萨切片》的视频能获得两亿次观看。这就是全世界最大的比萨切片。看它有多长。
This pizza is literally six feet until it's so loud. That's the basic volume of like 99% of it. And a few years back, he got into the ghost kitchen game. So he teamed up with virtual dining concepts, which is a company in the ghost kitchen space. And they launched a virtual restaurant brand called Mr. Beastburger. And so was this a traditional like ghost kitchen operation?
这个比萨真的有六英尺长，声音太大了。这基本上就是 99% 的音量。几年前，他也涉足了幽灵厨房领域。于是他与虚拟餐饮概念公司（Virtual Dining Concepts，一家幽灵厨房领域的公司）合作。他们推出了一个名为“野兽汉堡”（MrBeast Burger）的虚拟餐厅品牌。那么，这是一种传统的幽灵厨房运营模式吗？
Yeah, it is. And I'll get into how it actually works. But first there was this interesting thing, which is that to drum up support for Mr. Beast Burger and to get his millions of subscribers excited about it, Mr. Beast launched the concept with an actual brick and mortar restaurant that he set up in Wilson, North Carolina. So it had signs, it had branding, and it looked like a traditional fast food restaurant. I opened up the world's first free restaurant, and if that wasn't enough, I also paid people to eat at my restaurant. We haven't even opened
是的，确实如此。我会详细讲讲它是如何运作的。但首先有一个很有趣的事实，那就是为了给野兽汉堡造势，并让他的几百万订阅者感到兴奋，野兽先生在北卡罗来纳州威尔逊市建立了一家真正的实体餐厅来推出这个概念。所以它有招牌，有品牌标志，看起来就像一家传统的快餐店。我开办了世界上第一家免费餐厅，如果这还不够，我还付钱让人在我的餐厅吃饭。我们甚至还没开业
yet, and the police just told us to head to shut down a mile of traffic and there's a thousand cars in law. And this was a total stunt just to get attention, which seemed to work. But the interesting thing about this pop-up restaurant that he created is that it is not at all indicative of how Mr. Beastburger's actually work as a business because Mr. Beastberger is actually a ghost operation, so it's a delivery only restaurant chain which operates out of partner kitchens. Okay, so how does a partner kitchen relate to a ghost kitchen?
警察就叫我们去疏通长达一英里的交通，那里有一千辆汽车。这完全是一个为了吸引眼球的噱头，而且似乎成功了。但关于他创建的这家快闪店，有趣的一点在于，它完全不能代表野兽汉堡作为一项业务的实际运作方式，因为野兽汉堡实际上是一个幽灵运营项目，它是一个仅提供外卖的连锁餐厅网络，在合作厨房中运营。那么，合作厨房和幽灵厨房有什么关系呢？
So as an example, I searched for Mr. Beastberger in Albuquerque, New Mexico, which is like the nearest big city to me. And I found one. It was listed at an address. And when I searched for that address, it appeared to be a Bucadibepo Italian chain. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Wow.
举个例子，我在新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基搜索了野兽汉堡，那是离我最近的大城市。我找到了一家。它列在一个地址上。当我搜索那个地址时，它显示是一家布卡迪贝波意大利连锁店。哈哈哈哈。哇。
So Bucadibepo, they partnered with Mr. Beast to provide the Mr. Beast burger experience to the fine people of Albuquerque, New Mexico. Absolutely, yeah. So this is like another subtle twist on how these things work. And the pitch that Mr. Beastburger made when it launched in 2020, again,
所以布卡迪贝波与野兽先生合作，为新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基的可爱居民提供野兽汉堡的体验。没错，确实如此。所以这是这些运作方式的另一个微妙转折。野兽汉堡在2020年推出时的宣传点是，再说一次
it was the height of the pandemic, restaurants were struggling, and the idea was basically, here, we are going to hand you another revenue stream. This wildly popular YouTuber has all of these fans. They want Mr. Beast burgers, and you can sign up to be one of the providers making those burgers in your already established
当时正值大流行的高峰期，餐厅经营困难，这个想法基本上是，听着，我们要为你提供另一个收入来源。这位人气爆棚的 YouTuber 拥有所有这些粉丝。他们想要野兽汉堡，你可以报名成为在你现有的餐厅厨房里制作这些汉堡的供应商之一。
restaurant kitchen. Yeah, yeah. And Mr. Beast tried to make the menu simple so that it would suit lots of different kinds of restaurant kitchens. They wouldn't need new equipment. They wouldn't need special training. And so all these partnering restaurants have to do is make the burgers and then share the profits with Mr. Beast and virtual dining concepts.
对，对。野兽先生试图让菜单保持简单，以便适应许多不同类型的餐厅厨房。他们不需要新设备，不需要特殊培训。因此，所有这些合作餐厅所需要做的就是制作汉堡，然后与野兽先生和虚拟餐饮概念公司分享利润。
His partner is setting up the business. Right, right. To this business overall workout the business. Right. Right. To this business overall, work out for Mr. Beast. It's interesting because there are more than a thousand locations listed on the Mr. Beast Burger website. But I think this example highlights one of the tricky elements of being a virtual restaurant. And it's the fact that because Mr. Beast has outsourced all of the food
他的合伙人在建立这项业务。对，对。对这项业务整体而言，对野兽先生来说划算吗？这很有趣，因为在野兽汉堡的网站上列出了超过一千个地点。但我认为这个例子凸显了作为一家虚拟餐厅棘手的要素之一。那就是因为野兽先生将所有的食物采购和制作外包给了合作餐厅，质量控制一直是一个问题。一些顾客对汉堡的体验非常好，但其他人则有糟糕的体验。
buying and making two partner restaurants, quality control has been an issue. Some customers have had really good experiences with burgers, but other people have had bad experiences. So, I've seen that people have complained about the presentation being bad, about burgers arriving and random packaging. Like it doesn't look like a Mr. Beast burger. And then there's worse stuff too. Like some people have said they were delivered uncooked food or burgers on moldy buns. And this is actually escalated into Mr. Beast's suing virtual dining concepts, and then them suing him back.
所以，我看到有人抱怨呈现效果很差，汉堡送到时包装随意。看起来根本不像野兽汉堡。还有更糟糕的情况。比如有人说他们收到了未煮熟的食物或长霉汉堡胚上的汉堡。这实际上已经升级为野兽先生起诉虚拟餐饮概念公司，然后他们反诉他。
Oh my god, okay. Wow, that's fascinating. Yeah, it's still, it's an evolving realm. You know, there's some kings to be worked out. Well, I mean, there's something about the accountability of a place in physical space that is important, especially when you're talking about something as sort of fundamental as food. Yeah, I think what's interesting about it is that there does seem to be something deceptive about the whole ghost kitchen concept. Like, my old-fashioned expectation of a restaurant
天哪，好吧。哇，太迷人了。是的，这仍然是一个不断发展的领域。你知道，还有一些问题需要解决。嗯，我的意思是，实体空间中某个地方的问责制有一些重要之处，特别是当你谈论像食物这样基本的事情时。是的，我认为有趣的是，整个幽灵厨房的概念确实有些欺骗性。就像我老派的餐厅期望一样
is that it is a place, staffed by people who are trained to create a particular kind of food, that there's just this single integrated entity responsible for the quality of what I'm about to eat. And with ghost kitchens, it's just different. Like, it might be a commercial kitchen appearing to be lots of different, quote unquote, restaurants. It might be a Chuck E. Cheese masquerading as a Pusquale's. It might be an Italian chain, like making my burger and slapping a Mr. Beast sticker on it.
它是一个地方，由经过培训能够制作特定食物的人员组成，只有一个单一的综合实体对我要吃的食物质量负责。而对于幽灵厨房来说，情况完全不同。比如，它可能是一个商业厨房，伪装成许多不同的、所谓的“餐厅”。它可能是 Chuck E. Cheese 伪装成 Pasquale 的。它可能是一家意大利连锁店，制作我的汉堡并在上面贴上野兽先生的贴纸。
Yeah, it's very unusual. It's just a strange new world. Well, I'll be on the lookout because now I'm like gonna be really curious as to what I'm actually ordering from and they said an actual restaurant or not. Thank you so much for letting me appreciate. You're welcome. Thanks for having me and we'll make sure to post some of the videos we mentioned in our conversation on the website. Absolutely. We are indebted to Eddie Burback. Thanks for taking us on. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background Our next story is from Friend of the Show, LaVar Burton. He's got a new fiction podcast for kids and families called Sound Detectives, and it
是的，这很不寻常。这只是一个奇怪的新世界。好吧，我会留意的，因为现在我真的很想知道我到底是从什么地方订购的，他们说的是一家真正的餐厅还是别的什么。非常感谢你让我有所感激。不客气。谢谢邀请我，我们一定会把我们谈话中提到的一些视频发布到网站上。当然。我们感谢埃迪·伯巴克。谢谢你带我们领略。我们的下一个故事来自节目老朋友拉瓦尔·伯顿。他为儿童和家庭推出了一款名为《声音侦探》的新小说播客，它
plays an inventor who helps an unlikely pair of detectives return stolen sounds to the world. But today he's here with a true story about a lost sound. Here's Levar. I have a rather intriguing story to share about an enormous archaic instrument called the Tell Harmonium. For a monthly fee, you could simply pick up your phone and hear an entire orchestral performance. Only it wasn't an orchestra. It was a single instrument doing its best impression of an orchestra. Sadly, this marvel was never recorded, and it its sound has been lost to history. It all begins with the telharmoniums inventor, the ever-curious, fattiest K-Hill.
讲述了一位发明家帮助一对不太可能的侦探搭档将失窃的声音归还给世界的故事。但今天他带来的是一个关于失去声音的真实故事。有请拉瓦尔。我要分享一个相当引人入胜的故事，关于一种名为“电信和谐琴”的庞大古老乐器。只需支付月费，你就可以拿起电话听到整个管弦乐队的演奏。但这并不是管弦乐队。这只是一件竭尽全力模仿管弦乐队的单一乐器。可悲的是，这个奇迹从未被录音，它的声音已经湮没在历史中。这一切都从电信和谐琴的发明者、充满好奇心的法蒂乌斯·卡希尔开始。
K-Hill was reserved, studious, and incredibly smart. As early as 13, he was experimenting with music sent over telephone wires, an idea that would later become the tellharmonium. When he was just 18 years old, he filed his first patent. And he more would follow as he worked to improve devices like typewriters and pipe organs. This was just the start for K-Hill. He soon set his ambitions higher to develop a machine that could meticulously control the very shape of a sound wave. While other instruments used air or strings to produce their tones, K-Hill turned to something new, electricity. He began working on the ultimate instrument which K-. Hill patented in 1897 when he was 30 years old.
卡希尔性格内向、用功且极其聪明。早在13岁时，他就在实验通过电话线发送音乐，这个想法后来演变成了电信和谐琴。当他年仅18岁时，他申请了他的第一个专利。随着他致力于改进打字机和管风琴等设备，更多的专利随之而来。这只是卡希尔的开始。他很快将抱负定得更高，开发一台能够一丝不苟地控制声波精确形状的机器。虽然其他乐器使用空气或琴弦来产生音调，但卡希尔转向了一种新东西——电。他开始致力于终极乐器的研发，卡希尔于1897年在他30岁时获得了该乐器的专利。
This instrument would be able to perfectly replicate any other sound on Earth. The telharmonium was massive. It looked less like a grand piano or a cello, and like a power plant with 200 tons of large steel boxes and wires. It was a machine designed to play with the building blocks of sound. You can think of it like a painter's palette. The fundamental note is like a primary color. Think red, blue, or yellow.
这台乐器能够完美复制地球上的任何其他声音。电信和谐琴体型巨大。与其说它像一架三角钢琴或大提琴，不如说它更像一个发电厂，拥有200吨的大型钢箱和电线。这是一台旨在玩转声音构件的机器。你可以把它想象成画家的调色板。基本音就像原色。想想红、蓝或黄。
Overtones are much quieter notes that play alongside the fundamental. These are the subtle shades that give depth and complexity. Each instrument accentuates different overtones, giving you different sounds. This is part of why a piano sounds different than a violin, even if they're playing the same note. K-Hill wanted to choose and shape exactly which overtones we were hearing, allowing him to recreate any musical instrument he desired. He started with sine waves, the absolute purist form of sound.
泛音是伴随基本音播放的安静得多的音符。这些是赋予深度和复杂性的微妙色调。每种乐器都会突显不同的泛音，给你带来不同的声音。这也是为什么钢琴听起来与小提琴不同的一部分原因，即使它们演奏的是同一个音符。卡希尔想要精确选择和塑造我们听到的泛音，从而让他能够重现他想要的任何乐器。他从正弦波开始，这是声音最纯粹的形式。
They contained no overtones, just the fundamental note. The telharmonium used tone waves, massive cogs that spin at the frequency of the pitch to create these sign waves. Each note of the telharmonium had a tone wheel for the fundamental note, and up to 20 more for the overtones. This was all made a few years before the amplifier, meaning the telharmonium had to create an electrical current so strong that it wouldn't need to be amplified. To make that many notes that loudly required a large and expensive machine. K. Hill built a prototype and organized a demonstration. He played Handel's Largo for an audience of potential investors.
它们不包含泛音，只有基本音。电信和谐琴使用音轮，即以音高的频率旋转的大型齿轮来创建这些正弦波。电信和谐琴的每个音符都有一个用于基本音的音轮，多达20个或更多用于泛音。这一切都是在放大器发明前几年制造的，这意味着电信和谐琴必须产生足够强大的电流，以至于不需要放大。制造如此多的音符且声音如此之大，需要一台庞大而昂贵的机器。卡希尔建造了一个原型并组织了一场演示。他为潜在投资者观众演奏了亨德尔的《广板》。
While we can't play you an actual recording, we imagine it sounded something like this. The businessmen were amazed. With his project funded, Kay Hill constructed a full-scale telharmonium at his factory in Hollywood, New Jersey. It cost around $200,000, over $7 million, when adjusted for inflation. After its completion, the Telharmonium was shipped from K. Hills, New Jersey factory to its new home in Manhattan. It was set up in a building across from the Metropolitan Opera House, called Telharmonic Hall. The machines' mechanics were housed in the basement connected by wires to keyboards in the auditorium. The debut of Tell Harmonic Hall in 1906 was a roaring success.
虽然我们无法为您播放实际的录音，但我们想象它听起来像是这样的。商人们惊呆了。在项目获得资金后，卡希尔在他在新泽西州霍利奥克的工厂建造了一台全尺寸的电信和谐琴。它的成本约为20万美元，按通货膨胀调整后超过700万美元。完成后，电信和谐琴从卡希尔在新泽西州的工厂运到了曼哈顿的新家。它被安装在大都会歌剧院对面的一栋名为“电信和谐大厅”的建筑里。这台机器的机械装置存放在地下室，通过电线连接到礼堂的键盘。1906年电信和谐大厅的首演获得了巨大成功。
Demand was so high they doubled their daily shows and had to open up the basement to fit more visitors. One notable fan of the Telharmonium was author Mark Twain, who wrote, Every time I see or hear a new wonder like this, I have to postpone my death right off. I couldn't possibly leave the world until I have heard this again and again. Part of Cale's plan was a bold new idea, a musical subscription service.
需求如此之高，以至于他们将每日演出场次翻倍，并且不得不开放地下室以容纳更多游客。电信和谐琴的一位知名粉丝是作家马克·吐温，他写道：“每当我看到或听到像这样令人惊叹的新事物时，我都必须立刻推迟我的死亡。我绝对不能离开这个世界，直到我一次又一次地听到这个声音。”卡希尔计划的一部分是一个大胆的新想法，即音乐订阅服务。
Tell harmonic wires were strung up alongside telephone wires and subscribers could pay a monthly fee to listen at home on their phones. And, at least one hotel was constructed with tellic service available in every room. However, despite its novelty, there were a number of problems that plagued the tellharmonium. While some described it as pure of pitch and with a soothing quality, others complained that it was rather crude and lacking in variety. It was also hard to play, requiring two people to operate keyboards that were completely different from a piano or an organ.
电信和谐电线与电话线并排悬挂，订阅者可以支付月费在家里的电话上收听。而且，至少有一家酒店建成了每间客房都提供电信和谐服务的设施。然而，尽管它很新颖，但困扰电信和谐琴的问题有很多。虽然有些人形容它音高纯正且具有舒缓的品质，但其他人则抱怨它相当粗糙且缺乏多样性。它也很难演奏，需要两个人来操作与钢琴或风琴完全不同的键盘。
The business was impossible to scale. Each new subscriber required more electrical power. Eventually, the only way to keep up with demand would be to build an even bigger machine. The phone companies weren't too happy either. The teleharmonic music and regular phone calls ran on neighboring wires, and a much stronger teleharmonium signal would loudly bleed over and provide unexpected background music. In one anecdote, a woman suspected her husband was lying and calling from some concert hall instead of his office. All of these challenges were made even worse by the financial crisis of 1907. Subscriptions fell, and the attendance was so low
这项业务无法扩大规模。每个新订阅者都需要更多的电力。最终，跟上需求的唯一方法就是建造一台更大的机器。电话公司也不是很高兴。电信和谐音乐和普通电话在相邻的电线上运行，而更强的电信和谐信号会大声串音并提供意外的背景音乐。在一个轶事中，一位女士怀疑她丈夫在撒谎，是从某个音乐厅而不是他的办公室打电话来的。所有这些挑战都被1907年的金融危机雪上加霜。订阅量下降，出勤率非常低
that the Tell Harmonic Hall dropped performances to just once a day. The final show at Tell Harmonic Hall was on February 16, 1908. It's bright but brief time in the spotlight, lasting not quite two years. K. Hill tore down the telharmonium and retreated back to Hollywood. He began working on a cheaper and more efficient third model. In 1911, K. Hill spent five months disassembling, transporting and reconstructing this third telharmonium in New York, this time connecting it to Carnegie Hall. It received little fanfare.
以至于电信和谐大厅将演出缩减为每天仅一场。电信和谐大厅的最后一场演出是在1908年2月16日。它在聚光灯下闪耀但短暂的时光，持续了不到两年。卡希尔拆除了电信和谐琴并退回了霍利奥克。他开始致力于开发更便宜、更高效的第三代型号。1911年，卡希尔花 了五个月的时间在纽约拆卸、运输和重新组装这第三台电信和谐琴，这次将其连接到卡耐基音乐厅。它得到的反响寥寥。
Both the press and the public were no longer interested in dial-up music thanks to a new invention. The radio. What? What's your name? What's your name? What's your name? What's your name? A few years later, Kay Hill's company filed for bankruptcy with over $100,000 in debt, nearly $3 million today. All three tell harmoniums were eventually sold for scrap. K-heal died in 1934. That same year, the Hammond organ was invented, which used tone wheels coupled with newly developed amplifiers to make a similar and much more manageable instrument. It also used overtones to imitate pipe organs, but at a fraction of the sides. It was intended for churches, but then broke out as a staple of rock, soul, and blues music. While the sound of the telharmonium may have disappeared, its influence can still be seen
由于一项新发明的出现，媒体和公众都不再对拨号音乐感兴趣。收音机。什么？你叫什么名字？你叫什么名字？你叫什么名字？你叫什么名字？几年后，卡希尔的公司申请破产，负债超过10万美元，相当于今天的近300万美元。所有三台电信和谐琴最终都被当作废品卖掉了。卡希尔于1934年去世。同年，哈蒙德风琴被发明出来，它利用音轮加上新开发的放大器来制造类似且更易于管理的乐器。它还利用泛音来模仿管风琴，但尺寸只占一小部分。它原本是为教堂设计的，但后来爆发成为摇滚乐、灵歌和布鲁斯音乐的主打产品。虽然电信和谐琴的声音可能已经消失，但它的影响仍然可见
today. Synthesizers and other electronic instruments have made it easy to have an entire orchestra at your fingertips. Still, I can't help but imagine the enchanting sound of the tale harmonium. If you and your kids want to help Lavar find missing sounds, be sure to check out his new podcast Sound Detectives. You'll meet Detective Hunch and Audie, a literal walking and talking human ear, and you may also hear a familiar voice, let's just say I think I'd be a pretty good flight attendant. The first season of Sound Detectives is out now, wherever you get your podcasts.
今天。合成器和其他电子乐器让触手可得整个管弦乐队变得轻而易举。尽管如此，我还是忍不住想象电信和谐琴迷人的声音。如果你和你的孩子想帮拉瓦尔寻找失去的声音，一定要去看看他的新播客《声音侦探》。你会遇到“预感”侦探和奥迪（一个字面意义上会走会说的真正的人类耳朵），你可能还会听到一个熟悉的声音，只能说我认为我会成为一个相当不错的空乘人员。《声音侦探》第一季现已上线，无论你在哪里收听播客都可以听到。
99% Invisible With Produced This Week by Chris Perubek Delaney Hall, Kurt Coleset, and Talent Stratley. Mixed in Sound Design by Martin Gonzales. Music by Swan Rial and Martin Gonzales. Editing by Kelly Prime. Additional production by Jacob Moltenon Medina and Sarah Baik. Fact checking by Graham Haysha. Kethe 2 is our executive producer, the rest of the team, includes Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Jason Dillion, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney,
本周的《99%无形》由克里斯·佩鲁贝克、德兰尼·霍尔、库尔特·科塞特和塔伦·斯特拉特利制作。混音和声音设计由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责。音乐由斯旺·里尔和马丁·冈萨雷斯创作。编辑由凯利·普赖姆负责。额外制作由雅各布·莫尔特农·梅迪纳和莎拉·白负责。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙负责。凯特·科尔是我们的执行制片人，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、杰森·狄龙、拉谢马顿、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、
and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below-go was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks to Lavar Burton, Julia Smith, Isabelle Redmond Dolce, and Josephine Marta Rana. We are a part of this Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now a headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California.
还有我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。特别感谢拉瓦尔·伯顿、朱莉娅·史密斯、伊莎贝尔·雷德蒙·多尔克和约瑟芬·玛尔塔·拉娜。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼里。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。
You know what's really beautiful about Oakland right now? The Oakland Roots Soccer Club. Other teams come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first, always. We're on all the usual social media sites, but why spend your time doom scrolling there when you could visit somewhere good instead? 99pi.org. See you next year.
你知道现在奥克兰真正美妙的地方是什么吗？奥克兰根基足球俱乐部。其他球队来来去去，但根基队永远以奥克兰为先。我们在所有常见的社交媒体网站上，但当你本可以去某个好地方参观时，为什么要把时间浪费在无休止地上滑浏览上呢？请访问 99pi.org。明年见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。